[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis
weltreiche gibt es einen wunsch rezept
ich habe gefragt welches möchte dir als
nächstes sehen und ganz viele haben
geschrieben werden james cook
ihr kennt wahrscheinlich alle dieses eis
und die gibt es in diesem kleinen
handlichen bechern
es sind sage und schreibe 500 milliliter
drin aber das problem ist wenn man
einmal damit anfängt kann man nicht mehr
aufhören
das ist echt super lecker hat aber
natürlich auch einen gewissen preis
kostet die dose 599 für 500 milliliter
ist schon nicht wenig also ich finde
schon ziemlich kostenintensives eis so
siehts auf und die gibt es in
verschiedenen sorten die sorte cookies
und zwar ist es hier ein vanilleeis und
man sieht schon als ich habs jetzt nicht
lange draußen stehen in der mitte habe
ich diese cookie dough stückchen und die
sind echt total lecker also es natürlich
echt gerne und habe mir gedacht das
mache ich jetzt bei euch nach später
machen wir an der blindverkostung murat
darf dann probieren vorbild vergossen
aber nicht wir machen einfach den
vergleich oftmals ist aber so dass euch
das original einfach besser schmeckt
weil ihr denn geschmack gewohnt seid ist
auch bei milch schnitte so bei vielen
anderen süßigkeiten so ich habe viele
rezepte schon nach gemacht und es geht
ja auch nicht darum etwas besser zu
machen sondern einfach zu zeigen wie
kann man es dem selber machen
oftmals ist es auch nicht sinnvoll zu
sagen es wird ein günstiger dadurch weil
man braucht eben auch viele zutaten aber
hier bei diesem rezept kommen war sogar
auf einen günstigeren preis als dieses
eis ich bin mir jetzt noch rein und ich
zeige euch jetzt will ich das cookie
dough eismacher bei cookie dough hat man
das problem cookie dough diesen trend
gibt es schon seit dem letzten jahr
und letztes jahr gab es in amerika eine
große epidemie der krankheitsfälle und
das problem ist wenn man ruhen cookie
dough konsumiert dann kann man ganz
starke bauchschmerzen bekommen und auch
durchfall also eigentlich wollte ich
meine rezepte wieder nicht über
durchfall sprechen aber das problem
liegt nicht nur an den eiern viele
denken ja dass man durch die eier eben
salmonellen
bekommt da geht es übrigens übrigens
auch zum fall stecken die salmonellen
sitzen nämlich auf der eierschale und
kommen im prinzip nur in die als insider
der unsauber arbeitet also am besten die
eier nicht abwaschen sondern einfach
sauber arbeiten keine eierschale ins
gefäß fallen lassen und dann habt ihr
eigentlich normalerweise keine
salmonellen auch mit drin beim mehl ist
es so melis einfach ein naturprodukt
getreide wächst auf dem feld und jetzt
kann es zum beispiel passieren dass
vögel auf das getreide quoten und dann
wird ja eigentlich das mehl also die
gibt das getreide wird nur zum mehl
vermahlen und es wird nicht vorher
erhitzt das heißt ihr habt dann rohes
naturprodukt kann ja auch mal sein dass
die ziele oder kleine tierchen mit dem
mädchen das ist völlig normal ist ein
naturprodukt wird nicht behandelt
und deswegen ist bei kino ganz wichtig
hitze behandelt das mehl zu verwenden
und wähle den cookie doch selber macht
müsst ihr also daran denke neuer weg
lassen und das mehl vorher hoch erhitzen
im backofen zum beispiel da muss man es
einfach osten und deswegen gibt es
einfach die alternative cookie dough
direkt zum anmischen holen
da ist es mehr hitze behandelt und ihr
müsst einfach nur noch zwei zutaten zu
fügen also das so tokio nicht wundern
wenn ihr gucke doch selber macht und
bauchschmerzen bekommt das liegt am
nähen oder santana also nicht nur an den
eiern
so jetzt zeige ich mal eben die zutaten
bei mainz verzichte ich jetzt auf eine
einsame grundbasis denn ich habe ja
schon mal gezeigt wie man alles selber
macht einmal mit so einer richtigen
sahne basis und dann noch mal mit zwei
zutaten und heute machen wir nur die
zwei zutaten das war mit ihr alle am
einfachsten bzw drei zutaten und ich
stellt ihr euch eben mal vor wir den
korridor verwende ich also ein päckchen
cuche lag ogier in vanille geschmack 100
g weiche butter 60 gramm lauwarme milch
und hier habe ich noch die ice zutaten
für das grundrezept wenn nämlich 400
gramm gezuckerte kondensmilch 400 gramm
sahne und 100 teilen
ich hatte zuerst in quito an da habt ihr
einmal das päckchen mit dem cookie dough
also mit dem pulver und einmal streusel
mit dabei
es geht jetzt ganz einfach wichtig ist
nur dass milch und butter relativ
zimmertemperatur haben
[Musik]
danach die milch statt so und dann
einfach mit der küchenmaschine oder mit
dem handrührgerät für etwa zwei minuten
verwirren
jetzt gibt die entweder die
schokostreusel mit rein
ich nenne jetzt aber dieser schoko drops
die sind nämlich auch beim ben jerry's
mit drin
also hat es einfach kurz ausgetauscht
[Musik]
es ist der kitt euro bereits zubereitet
und so kann man ihnen jetzt auch essen
also naschen und da gibt es ja auch
eisdielen als eisdielen sind sich aber
gucke downloaden
die eben gerade so cookie dough
zubereiten und dann mit toppings machen
wie erdbeeren heidelbeeren brombeeren
usw oder kekse und sowieso ein eisbecher
vergleich zu mir und wir machen das auch
total gerne warum können sie es ja auch
selber mischen
jetzt nehme ich einfach einen kleinen 1
portionierer und fühlt dann immer so bis
zur hälfte und setzen jetzt diese
teigklumpen einfach auf dem backpapier
bzw eine back folie und frier sie dann
für etwa zehn minuten ein
dann kann ich sie nämlich mit den händen
einfach zu kugeln formen
[Musik]
die habe ich jetzt die drei ice zutaten
und das ist wirklich so ein grundrezept
für eis könnt ihr immer mal ganz schnell
machen kondensmilch die zucker da habe
ich immer da und da gibt es auch ein
großer unterschied und ich glaube es war
auch der punkt stehen viele halt
römertagen beim einem riesen sneakers
rezept des tickets oder kondensmilch und
man sieht auch dieses richtig
dickflüssig und dann gibt es noch die
ganz normale kondensmilch die fließt und
werde die nimmt ist einfach kein super
drin ist zwar auch ein bisschen ist aber
die ich einfach viel zu tun und wir
brauchen diese gezuckerte die dicke
kondensmilch sahne und dann gebe ich
noch den joghurt dazu einfach alles
geschmacksträger und der bringt einfach
nur ein schönes teure kein witz ist dass
die zutaten alle ganz kalt sind ich
hatte die jetzt eben nochmal so zehn
minuten im gefrierschrank habe ich
zuerst die sa nehmen rührt ob nun kann
die kurz stadt schlagen
[Musik]
susanne satz steigt ob es mir immer
aufpassen denn die küchenmaschine hat
sehr viel power also nicht überschlagen
jetzt kommt ihr der zucker kondensmilch
dazu gesagt eben auch dafür dass das eis
schön cremig ist ist natürlich auch
nicht kalorienarm
damit haben jetzt viel fett und viel
zucker dadurch 40 in kremitz dass mein
mann ist ja zum genuss und ich gebe noch
den joghurt dazu verriet aber vorher
kurz glatt
[Musik]
denn es hat so eine gelbliche farbe weil
sie einfach hitze behandelt ist da ist
der zucker mit dabei und der
karamellisiert dann einfach ein bisschen
kurz unter rühren aber nicht so lange
rühren so dass die luftige konsistenz
nicht zerstört wird
jetzt kann ich diese eismasse entweder
ohne eismaschine zu bereiten dann geht
er wie folgt vor neben dieser wasser
geschüttet sie ihnen ein großes pech zum
beispiel oder eine große vor
und dann kommt ins gefrierfach etwa drei
bis vier stunden und alle halbe stunde
hört ihr einmal durch und damit das eis
super predigt ich arbeite jetzt mit der
eismaschine
da habe ich einfach die ständige
bewegung und es dauert auch nur 20 30
uhr
wenn ihr platz hat ist es immer von
vorteil dieses gerät immer im eisfach zu
haben so könnt ihr nämlich spontan auch
mal ein eis machen
es muss nämlich 24 stunden frieren oder
am besten mindestens über nacht die
röhre elemente habe ich dann auch immer
im gefrierfach und jetzt ist ganz
wichtig das eis erst einführen wenn die
maschine läuft
[Musik]
früheren und dann das eis einzeln wenn
ihr nämlich direktes eisen die maschine
fühlt ohne zu rühren dann gefriert es am
boden fest und alles bekommt vorsichtig
einfüllen
[Musik]
jetzt lass dir so die ice grund maße für
etwa 20 bis 30 minuten rühren bis sie
eine schöne feste konsistenz hat es gebe
es noch ein bisschen geschmack dazu
vanille extrakt ich möchte ja dass mein
eis besser schluckt
[Musik]
jetzt ist das eis fertig hat eine
richtig schöne konsistenz ich gebe es
hier noch so komplexen mit reinen diesen
nimmt beim jerry's auch mit dabei ich
will da so originalgetreu wie möglich
machen
[Musik]
jetzt ist wichtig ich habe jetzt hier
eine flache schüssel die habe ich auch
schon eingefroren
die cookie dough bands in dem auch schon
gefroren schaut mal wie schön dass es
aussieht
jetzt könnte das eis im prinzip direkt
offen
jetzt hat die konsistenz von softeis
oder friert eben noch mal ein also ich
fress jetzt noch mal ein damit war
richtig schönes festes eis haben was ich
jetzt echt cool finde wenn ihr es gleich
verzehrt ist es ja wirklich schon fest
dann habt ihr wirklich innerhalb von
einer halben stunde und selbstgemachtes
eis mit diesem rezept also schon gut
geht schneller als loszuziehen und ben
jerry's zu kaufen
[Musik]
es ist wichtig dass es nicht dem eis
behälter lagern da kriegt man es nicht
schlecht wieder raus erzählt die flache
edelstahl schale dieser gucke dollar ein
man muss auch wissen selbst gemachtes
eis hält nicht so lange wie gekauft das
alles natürlich habe auch keine
konservierungsmittel und keine stand
mittel mit drin das heißt es schmilzt
auch schneller aber es ist total lecker
und ihr wisst was ihr drin hat
[Musik]
die andere hälfte kann hier ein free und
habt ihr schon direkt vorbereitet das
nächste mal dann gibt es nämlich noch
schneller
ich friere des eises noch ein für etwa
eine stunde damit stellt fest ist und
dann wird probiert
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt fairerweise auch dass ben
jerry's bisschen draußen stehen lassen
damit es eben ungefähr auch die gleiche
konsistenz annimmt und man muss es ja
auch große raum teltow stehen lassen
weil es ansonsten zu hart ist jung
swisscom ok probiert jetzt einmal das
war natürlich die kopie ist die höchste
hilfswerke anerkennung als poppea und
nur dinge die ich getan habe richtig
angst dass jetzt morgen wie angeklagt
werden wegen urheberrechtsverletzung ben
jerry's nein ich habe nichts damit zu
tun ich bin nur der hausmeister das sind
fast keinen unterschied geben befragung
sind rechtlich kurs im garten nicht
siehst du ich komme aus den daten und
mehr bekommst du vom bildschirm wir
haben uns ja wenn ich sagen ja nichts
weiß ein produktplatzierung zehn mal so
ich habe schon original
ich habe auch schon erklärt oftmals
schmeckt er mir das original besser weil
meist auch eigengeschmack gewohnt das
ist auch bei anderen dingen mal kennzahl
einfach so kennt den typischen geschmack
das video ist schon gut so ziemlich
leckeres eis aber ist auch sehr teuer
also dann kostet der becher sechs euro
pro 100 gramm sind etwa 150
und das selbst gemachte eis und das
jetzt ist ja alles schmiert objekt und
das selbst gemachte eis kostet pro 100
gramm nur 50 cent inklusive der
kompletten park cookie dough und da habe
ich ja noch die hälfte übrig für die
nächste portion also erstmal richtung
kanal 40 sind schon einen drittel
die spiele des counter und kunstkreis
wie die chinesen probiert alles jetzt
meister ließ ich war mal politisch
ehrlich 50 cent nur ja
der von dir sogar noch cremiger also der
frau jerry hall komiker kevin james habe
ich auch gleich beim essen
der hat wie zucker christen die haben
auch braunen zucker in ihrem kokon und
ich habe die küche guido mischung die
man eben nicht mehr hitze worden weil
noch mehr steuern handelt das liebe geld
in cherry community oder gleich das
unternehmen auch das meint auch er würde
man sagen tut mehr gucken nur ein
wirklich geschmeckt als mainz
weggegessen das lesen culum erreicht
aber es um noch besser zu werden ja
heute den namen her gebraucht wie nummer
namen milky way mini mac kennt ihr das
noch keine schlüsse ist es ja genau wie
schmelzer ich werde genauso wie
minimieren und mit keks drin
also ich glaube bei diesem video müssen
als dauerwerbesendung schreiben ist
allerdings alles erwähnter gehabt dass
nicht wieder ein eyecatcher dann ist
jetzt noch gefällt ganz ganz wichtig
also praktisch keine produktplatzierung
für ja ich hab's ja kopiert habe es eine
produktplatzierung küche ist ja sagen ja
er wollte den jahren dauer also kritik
und doch es gibt mir noch mal könnte
noch smarties reinmachen ja aber achtung
der hammer edge switches lust auf ein
eis ok und sagt oh mein gott ich würde
gerne ben & jerry's cookie dough eis
essen
jetzt musst du von hier los waren zum
globus steht in der schlange
hermannstadt sibiu nach sind aber die
brauchen ungefähr eine stunde wegfahren
wiederkommt und das selbst gemacht und
ist dokumentiert und verstehen was ich
mache
das selbst gemachte eis hast du
innerhalb von einer halben stunde halbe
stunde das eisfeld ist und so viel wir
sind da ja noch die schauen weil du
kannst diese diesem cookie dough
anrühren dann kommt man ins gespräch
eine portion habe ich jetzt schon bereit
für das nächste und das eis oder 20
minuten fertig gestellt könnte jetzt mal
aufhören
die wenig bezahlt bekommen wenn bei uns
ein wenn unbezahlte produktplatzierungen
vor sich dieses video enthält und
bezahlte produktplatzierungen wie so
etwas passieren sagt so jetzt jemand
dessen 90
ich habe die ganze wollen das große kino
stück und vor allem habe ich erst mit
dieser einen rezept menge habe ich viel
mehr 11 in einen becher schmeckt lecker
jetzt könnt ihr mir sagen welche ben
jerry's eis war jetzt um ihr gerne noch
sehen wollt ihr könnt auch gerne
schreiben welches eis soll ich als
nächstes zu bereiten oder gewinne und
spaß machen es ist einfach dann murat
ince ellison und ich hab mir überlegt
ich mache noch so ein gesundes also ohne
zucker und keine ahnung erst mal ganz
ehrlich wir machen einfach weiter
ein gesundes habe ich übrigens gemacht
ich habe diese eines muffins gemacht auf
dem globus kanal könnte mal schauen und
zwar bestehen die aus frozen yogurt aus
erpressen das ist so eine art müsli und
joghurt eis und das ohne industriezucker
da können wir gerne rein schauen und
wenn euch dieses rezept gefallen hat
dann schaut doch mal gerne an auch janis
minins doch die steht nämlich alles mit
oder ohne eismaschine um ganz wie ihr
wollt
ich wollte guten produkttester und der
manipuliert und ist doch gar nicht und
das war muss antworten müssen wir alles
vergessen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und das problem ist wenn man ruhe und
kokain konsumiert cockpit